فالبيت الابيض يستبق القمه الروسيه
الصينيه برفض اي دعوه من بكين لوقف اطلاق
النار في اوكرانيا
مصارف مركزيه كبرى تعلن عن تحرك منسق
لتوفير مزيد من السيوله لطمانه الاسواق
توقيع الاتفاق السياسي النهائي في السودان
مطلع ابريل والبرهان يؤكد على هدف الحكومه
المدنيه
[موسيقى]
نشره اخباريه جديده من العربيه اهلا بكم
عشيه اجتماعه مع الرئيس الصيني شيمبان في
موسكو ندد الرئيس روسيا بما اسماها سياسه
امريكا لاحتواء روسيا والصين مشيرا الى
انها تاخذ طابعا حادا غير مسبوق وفي مقاله
نشرت في صحيفه الشعب الصينيه وصحيفه
كما رجح الرئيس الروسي ان حجم التبادل
التجاري مع بكين هذا العام قد يتجاوز 200
مليار دولار مشددا على ضروره زياده
التبادل التجاري مع الصين بالعملات
الوطنيه بوتين اضاف ايضا ان في خلال مقاله
ان العلاقات بين موسكو وبكين في قمتها
وانه سيتم مواصلته تعزيزها لافتا الى ان
زياره الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا تجسد
الطابعه الخاص لشراكه بين البلدين
اما في الولايات المتحده المتحده باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي بالبيت الابيض
جون كيرربي استبق في حديث قناه فوكس
نيوزلندي القمه الروسيه الصينيه بالقول ان
الولايات المتحده سترفض اي دعوه لوقف
اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا تخرج من اجتماع
الرئيسين الروسي والصيني في موسكو كما
اذا خرج من هذا الاجتماع نوع من الدعوه
لوقف اطلاق النار حسنا سيكون هذا غير
مقبول ان كل ما سيفعلهم هو التصديق على
غزو روسيا حتى الان كل ما سيفعله هو اعطاء
السيد بوتين مزيدا من الوقت لاعاده
التاهيل واعاده التدريب والبقاء ومحاوله
التخطيط لهجمات متجدده في الوقت الذي
يختاره نامول وقد قلنا هذا من قبل ان
السيد الرئيس شي سوف يتصل ويتحدث مع
الرئيس زيلينسكي ونعتقد ان الصينيين بحاجه
للحصول على المنظور الاوكراني
كما قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي بالبيت الابيض في حديثه لقناه
فوكس ان روسيا والصين غاضبتان من النظام
الدولي الحالي وتريداني تغييره
ليس هناك شك في ان كل من الصين وروسيا
دوله تنزعج من هذا النظام الدولي القائم
على القواعد التي انشاتها الولايات
المتحده والعديد من حلفائنا وشركائنا منذ
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه انهم لا
يحبون ذلك انهم يرغبون في اعاده كتابه
قواعد اللعبه على مستوى العالم وقد زادوا
من تعاونهم وعلاقتهم بالتاكيد في الاونه
الاخيره
اما ميدانيا ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وفي اول زياره له الى اقليم دومباس
منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا تجول في مدينه
ماريوبول الاوكرانيه كما تفقد عددا من
المرافق فيها زياره قال مراقبون انها تحمل
الكثير من الرسائل
مترجلا يتجول بوتين في ماريوبل اشهر المدن
الاوكرانيه في ذاكره العالم هنا قاد
سيارته بنفسه وهنا وقف تحت نصب اوكراني
يعلوه على مرسي وقفه برسائل ودلالات كثيره
الرئيس الروسي اختار المدينه التي تشكل
رمزا للمقاومه الاوكرانيه وقلب اوكرانيا
الصناعي واقربها الى خط نار المعارك
المستعره منذ سنه ونيف الزياره المفاجئه
تعتبر الاولى لبوتين الى المناطق التي
استولت عليها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتاتي بعد يومين فقط من اصدار
مذكره توقيف بحقه وبالتزامن مع الذكرى
التاسعه لضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرم وفقا
لوسائل اعلام الروسيه فان سيد الكرملين
زار مدرسه ومركزا للاطفال في شبه جزيره
القرش عرض يقول مراقبه انه تحدي لمن اتهمه
بقتل اطفال اوكرانيا وترحيل الاف منهم الى
روسيا
الملك تاتي زياره قبل زياره مرتقبه لشي
جين بينك حليف بوتين الابرز وفي وقت يتكتل
فيه حلفاء كييف الغربيون لدعم هجومها
المرتقب في الربيع هجوم تقول انها تريد من
خلاله استعاده اراضيها المسلوبه ما بينما
استولت عليه موسكو وما تريده كييف وقف
بوتي وقفه قال فيها الكثير وان لم يتحدث
رائد المصطفى العربيه
وفي رد فعلك على هذه الزياره انتقد مساعد
رئاسه الاوكراني ميخائيل بوتولياك وجود
رئيس روسيا
بول الساحليه الاوكرانيه والتي استولت
عليها القوات الروسيه العام الماضي كما
وصف بودلياك بوتين بالمجرم الذي يعود
دائما الى مسرح الجريمه وانه قتل الالاف
في ماريوبول وهو سعيد بمشاهده المدينه
ومقابرها وغير نادم على حد وصف بودولياك
بعد ان اصدرت مذكره توقيف بحق بوتين بات
السؤال الاهم كيف يمكن للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ان تطبق قرارها بحق الرئيس الروسي
لا سيما انها بلا جيش وبلا قوه عسكريه
من سيقبض على بوتين وكيف بعدما اصبح
مطلوبا للعداله الدوليه بدعوى ارتكابه
جرائم حرب وبامر من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
المحكمه ذات الولايات القضائيه العالميه
تختص بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن جرائم الحرب
والاباده الجماعيه عندما لا تستطيع
السلطات الوطنيه القيام بذلك وهذا في
الدول 123 التي وقعت على معاهده انشائها
روسيا ليست واحده منها ليس للمحكمه شرطه
او قوات عسكريه
وتعتمد على السلطات المدنيه في اعتقال
وتسليم المطلوبين قرارات المحكمه تواجه
اشكاليه تتمثل في رفض الدول تسليم
المتهمين
اشكاليه واجهتها في تسليم الرئيس السوداني
السابق عمر البشير اذ رفضت عده دول واقعه
على ميثاق المحكمه
التعاون في اعتقاله بما في ذلك تشاد
وكينيا ويعتبر الرئيس الروسي ثاني رئيس
تصدر بحقه مذكره اعتقال وهو على راس عمله
بعد البشير
واقتصرت بقيه المذكرات على قاده عسكريين
ومسؤولين ارتكبوا جرائم حرب في الحاله
الروسيه يمكن اعتقال بوتين في حالات
محدوده كان يغادر بلده الى دوله قد ترغب
بتقديمه للمحاكمه او ان تسلمه سلطات بلاده
وفي بلد يتمتع بوتين فيه بسلطه مطلقه فانه
من غير المتوقع ان يسعى الكرملين الى
تقديمه للمحكمه الدوليه
المذكره لا معنى لها يقول الكرملين بينما
ينظر اليها الغرب كاشاره من المجتمع
الدولي الى ان ما يحدث في اوكرانيا مخالف
للقانون
وبين هذا وذاك لا احد يستطيع القبض على
بوتين
انضم مجلس الاحتياء الاحتياطي الاتحاديه
الى بنوكي كندا وانجلترا واليابان والبنك
المركزي الاوروبي والبنك الوطني السويسري
في اجراء ملصق لتعزيز توفير السيوله من
خلال ترتيبات خطوط مبادله الدولار
وتشير هذه الخطوه الى شده قلق محافظ
البنوك المركزيه بشان الاضطرابات الاخيره
في النظام المالي في اوروبا والولايات
المتحده
وتاتي الخطوه بعد اعلان الرئيس السويسري
نبا استحواذى العملاق على منافسه كريدي
سويس مقابل ثلاثه مليارات و230 مليون
دولار ووصف الرئيس السويسري الاتفاق بانه
احد العوامل الهامه لتحقيق الاستقرار في
سوق التمويل الدولي لان الانهيار غير
المنضبط من شانه ان يؤدي الى عواقب لا حصر
لها لسويسرا ونظام الماليه العالمي على حد
قوله بدوره قال رئيس بنك سويس ان التطورات
الاخيره في البنوك الامريكيه ضربت البنك
في وقت غير مناسب مشيرا الى ان صفقه
الاندماج مع يو بي اس ستوفر الامانه
والاستقرار في ذات السياق اعلن البنك
المركزي السويسري تقديم مساعده ماليه على
هيئه قروض ب18 مليارات دولار لكل من يو بي
اس وكريدي سويس
هذا وقال البنك المركزي الاوروبي ان انقاذ
بنك السويسري كان ضروريا لاستعاده الهدوء
في الاسواق الماليه وانه لا يزال مستعدا
لدعم بنقي منطقه اليورو بالقروض اذا لزم
الامر ورحبت كريستيلا جارد رئيسه البنك في
بيان بالاجراء السريع والقرارات التي
اتخذتها السلطات السويسريه والتي كانت
ضروريه لاستعاده اوضاع السوق المنتظمه
وضمان الاستقرار المالي كما اضافت ان
القطاع المصرفيه في منطقه اليورو يتمتع
بالمرونه مع وجود مراكز قويه لراس المال
والسيوله
في تطور جديد في الازمه السودانيه اعلن
المتحدث الرسمي باسم العمليه السياسيه
خالد عمر يوسف ان الاطراف توافقت على
توقيع الاتفاق النهائي لحل الازمه
السياسيه في البلاد في الاول من شهر ابريل
القادم سيتم توقيع الاتفاق النهائي يوم
واحد ابريل القادم ان شاء الله
وسيتم التوقيع على الدستور الانتقالي يوم
سته ابريل على ان تبدا تشكيل مؤسسات
السلطه الانتقاليه يوم 11 ابريل
المقبل المواقيت يتفق عليها في اجتماع
النهار اليوم بحضور الفريق
حمدان
الثلاثيه والالياف الرباعيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي وايضا تمت مراجعه ترتيباتك مع
السادسه والنصف كامل المتوقعين وبعض القوه
غير المواقع الاتفاق الايطالي انها تنضم
لهذا الاجتماع لكي تشكل مع بقيه القوى
الموقعه على الاتفاق الاطار العاليه
اللجنه المختصه بالصيانه ولكن
بكل اسف في اللحظه الاخيره اعتقد اصدر بعض
هذه القوه مواقف معلنه بعدم حضور الاجتماع
وقلع عمر انه تم تشكيل اللجنه السياسيه
الخاصه بالصياغه الاتفاق النهائي وفق
المرجعيات التي تم الاتفاق عليها الاليه
التي اجتمعت مساء اليوم في القصر الجمهوري
هي ما يعني ما ما جهه جديده من الاتفاق
عندما مهمه فقط محدده هي اختيار اللجنه
الصياغه لصيانه الاتفاق النهائي ومن ثم
المتابعه مع لجنه الصياغه لضمان ان تفرغ
من عملها وفقا للمواقيت المتفق عليها يعني
ستبدا رياضه صياغه عملها ان شاء الله
ابتداء من اليوم الغد
في غضون ذلك اكد رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان
اكد ان المؤسسه العسكريه لن تتراجع عن هدف
الوصول الى حكومه مدنيه البرهان اضاف ايضا
ان عزمه نحو الوصول الى الحكومه المدنيه
غير قابل للابتزاز او المساومه على حد
وصفه مشيرا الى اقتراب مرحله ترك المجال
للقوه المدنيه تلبيه للرغبه الشعبيه دون
المؤسسات العسكريه
هذه نشره مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يهدد بتنفيذ هجوم
نووي في اي وقت
في تطور غير مسبوق اسرائيليا اصبح التهديد
واقعا حيث لم يلتحق 180 طيارا حربيا
وملاحا جويا من الاحتياط والعشرات من
مشغلي المسيرات والعاملين في مجال السايبر
بوحداتهم وانضموا الى بدء 650 من مقاتلي
الوحدات الخاصه السريه من الاحتياط
عصيانهم العسكري ايضا احتجاجا على ما بات
يسمى بمحاوله انقلاب الحكومه على نظام
القضاء في اسرائيل
اتوقع من رئيس الاركان وقاده الاجهزه
الامنيه التصدي بحزم لرفض الخدمه العسكريه
ليس هناك مكان للاسيان العسكري في السجال
العام دوله ترغب في البقاء لا يمكنها
التسليم بظواهر كهذه ظاهره رفض الخدمه في
صفوف قوات الاحتياط التي تشكل عماد الجيش
الاسرائيلي ونصف القوه العملانيه لسلاح
الجو مرشحه للاتساع في ظل استمرار تظاهرات
الاحتجاج الحاشده واصرار الحكومه على
المضيف خطه تغيير نظام القضاء واضعاف
المحكمه العليا وسط تحضيرات متواتره من ان
تقود بوادر العنف الى حرب اهليه
كما دوما فاننا امام امكاني تدهور امني
على عده جبهات وممنوع علينا ان تدور حرب
اخوه على جبهتنا الداخليه نتنياهو توقف
على الاقل الى ما بعد شهر رمضان
الخشيه لدى القياده العسكريه والامنيه من
ان يؤدي وصول الانقسام الى صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى انهيار موقع الاجماع شبه
الوحيد في المجتمع الاسرائيلي وان تتراجع
معنويات القتال فيما تنتظر اسرائيل تحديات
خارجيه فايران تلامس القدره النوويه
العسكريه وحزب الله اختبر اسرائيل في
عمليه مجدو في العمق وثم التخوف من اندلاع
حرب جديده على قطاع غزه وانفجار الوضع في
الضفه في شهر رمضان المغترب
بعد ان وصل الانقسام في الشارع الاسرائيلي
الى صفوف الجيش من خلال موجه رفض الخدمه
من قبل نخب قتاليه في الاحتياط يرى
مراقبون بان ذلك سيمس بجاهزيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي القتاليه في مواجهه تحديات
قريبه وبعيده وقد يؤدي الى اختبار جهات
خارجيه للواقع الاسرائيلي المازوم عسكريا
وهو يقرا ضعفا ووهنا زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه
بحث رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن هاتفيا مع
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين تنياهو
خفض التوتر بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
البيت الابيض قال في بيان ان بايدن ابدى
دعمه للجهود الراميه للتوصل الى تسويه
بشان اصلاحات قضائيه مزمعه كما عرض بايدن
دعم الجهود الجاريه للتوصل الى حل وسط
بشان الاصلاحات القضائيه المقترحه
هذا وقد اصدرت مصر والاردن والولايات
المتحده واسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه
بيانا مشتركا بشان اجتماع الامس في مدينه
شرم الشيخ واكد البيان على ضروره تحقيق
الهدنه على الارض ووقف العنف بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين كما جددت
اسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه وقف الاجراءات
الاحاديه لفتره بين ثلاثه الى سته اشهر مع
وقف مناقشه المستوطنات الجديده لاربعه
اشهر ايضا اعلن البيان عن استحداث اليه
لوقف العنف والتحريض مع رفع تقارير الى
قيادات الدول الخمس مع ضروره ضمان مواجهه
اي استفزازات في المواقع المقدسه بما في
ذلك خلال شهر رمضان البيان اكد ايضا على
ارساء اليه من اجل تحسين الوضع الاقتصادي
للشعب الفلسطيني كما اكد ايضا البيان ان
اسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه اتفقطا على
الالتزام بكل الاتفاقات السابقه بينهما
كما تقرر السمرار الاجتماعات على المستوى
الخماسي من اجل وضع اساس لاجراء مفاوضات
مباشره بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
للتوصل الى سلام
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اعتقال منفذ اطلاق
النار على مستوطنين اثنين في بلده حواره
جنوب نابلس والذي اسفر عن اصابه مستوطنين
اثنين احدهما في حاله خطره الجيش
الاسرائيلي اوضح في بيان ان منفذ العمليه
مع اعتقاله بعد مطارده مشيرا الى اصابه
منفذ الهجوم ويجرى التحقيق معه حاليا
هدد زعيم كوريا الشماليه بتنفيذ هجمات
نوويه في اي وقت لمواجهه تهديدات امريكا
وكوريا الجنوبيه على حد قوله ونقلت وكاله
انباء كوريا الشماليه عن كيم جونغ اون
اتهامه لواشنطن وسول بتوزيع بتوسيع
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بما في ذلك
القدرات النوويه الامريكيه في السياق اكدت
كوريا الشماليه اجراء تدريبات عسكريه على
مدار اليومين الماضيين في محاكاه لهجوم
نووي تكتيكي بما في ذلك اطلاق صاروخ
باليستي يحمل راسا نوويا وهميا
قالت شركه هولنديه انها ستبدا في سحب
النفط الخام من خزان صافر قباله السواحل
اليمنيه خلال يونيو ويوليو وحتى منتصف
اوسوس وفي افتتاح ورشه العمل الخاصه بخطه
تشغيل مشروع انقاذ صافر والمنعقده في عدن
قالت الشركه انها ستتخلص من الخزان القديم
المتهالك عبر تفكيكه كما تطرق وزير النقل
اليمني عبد السلام حميد الى مخاطر حدوث
تسريب او انفجار للخزان على منطقه البحر
الاحمر وخطوط الملاحه داعيا لتحرك سريع
لبدء تفريغ الخزان وحشد الموارد الماليه
لتغطيه فجوه تقدر ب 30 مليون دولار
في اليمن يعاني سكان محافظه تعز من ارتفاع
اجور العقارات لا سيما الشقق السكنيه التي
ارتفعت الى اكثر من مائه في المائه في
الاونه الاخيره ولجات عشرات الاسر الى
اخلاء سبيل الشقق السكنيه والعيش في
دكاكين صغيره تفتقر للنوافذ والتهويه ولا
تصلح حتى للعيش
قد لا تبدو المدينه هذه المزدحمه بالسكان
قادره على استيعاب المزيد من الناس ولا
سكانها انفسهم قادرين على دفع تكاليف
السكن فالاسر الفقيره هنا وخاصه للنازحه
اتخذت من هذه الدكاكين مسكنا لها بعد رفع
ملاك العقارات اجور الشقق السكنيه في تعز
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه
الدقون على قدر على قدر حالي اما الشقه
مقدرش يستاجر شقه ابدا نهائيا لان الوضع
اننا اداره ارتفعوا الاسعار احنا ما نقدرش
150 150 180 الايجار حق الشقق نجحنا
لعينين من نحن سبعه بل هذا الدكان والله
ان احنا ما يساحنه ولا حاجه من احنا سبعه
بنتي شباب بسبب ان احنا ما نقدر نستعجل
شقه ليست هذه الاسره وحدها من اضطرت للعيش
في مكان يفتقر لنافذه واحده بل هناك
العشرات من الاسر واجهه المصير ذاته بعد
ارتفاع اجور الشقق السكنيه الى 150 الف
ريال للشهر الواحد اوضع ماساويه صعبه
تعيشها هذه الاسر في اماكن اشبهوا بالسجون
مع ترد الوضع المعيشي وانقطاع الرواتب
وتراجع الثرث العمل في البلد
شربنا كسوه العيد مصاري في رمضان
على حسب الظروف حاولنا جاهدين على ان نقنن
هذه المساله وقلنا يجب ان يرفع
بالجانب المنطقي وهو عشره في المئه الى
عشرين في المئه اما ان يرفع 200 الى 300%
فهذا شيء غير مقبول هكذا اذا بدا مسكن
الاسر الفقيره في المدينه هذه وهكذا بدا
حالهم مع ارتفاع اجور السكن امر دفع بعض
الاسر الى مغادره المدينه التي تفتقر الى
اليات تنظم الاجور بين المواطن وملاك
العقارات
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه اذا ارتفعت اجور
العقارات والشقق السكنيه داخل محافظه تعز
وهو من عكس سلبا على الحياه المعيشيه
للمواطن اليمني لكن الجهات الحكوميه تحاول
جاهده الحد من هذه الاشكاليه هل سعيد
العربيه تعز
رصدت جهات علميه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تضخما في حجم الطحالب الحمراء
وقد ادت هذه الكميه الكبيره من الطحالب
لنفوق عددا من الاسماك بل وتشويه الواجهه
البحيره لبحيره عده عدد من الشواطئ في
الولايات المتحده
امواج من الطحالب الحمراء على مد الشواطئ
الامريكيه الغربيه وفي عدد من جزر
الكاريبي ظاهره اثارت الهلع بسبب ضخامتها
فقد بينت صور الاقمار الصناعيه ان المد
الاحمر او ما يسمى علميا
يصل حجمه الى مرتين من مساحه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
منذ عشر سنوات هذه هي المره الاولى التي
نرى هذه الظاهره بهذا الحجم تكاثر الطحالب
ادى الى نفوق عدد من الاسماك وحتى بعض
الحيتان وذلك لان هذا النوع يمتص الاكسجين
الموجوده في المياه فيتسبب في اختناق
الاحياء البحريه ولكن العلماء ما زالوا
غير متاكدين من سبب هذه الموجه
يمكننا علاج هذا الامر اذا حددنا سبب
التكاثر وقد تضاعف حجم موجه الطحالب مرتين
بين ديسمبر يناير يعتقد العلماء ان
الاحتباس الحراري هو من اسباب تضخم حجم
الطحالب التي بتكاثرها تزيد نسبه الملوثات
في مياه البحر التي قد تتبخر لتسقط مع
الامطار لتؤثر بذلك على المحاصيل الزراعيه
وعلى صحه البشر ان اسم ماسي العربيه
في نهايه هذه النشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
البيت الابيض يستبق القمه الروسيه الصينيه
برفض اي دعوه من بكين لوقف اطلاق النار في
اوكرانيا
مصارف مركزيه كبرى تعلن عن تحرك منسق
لتوفير مزيد من السيوله لطمانه الاسواق
توقيع الاتفاق السياسي النهائي في السودان
مطلع ابريل والبرهان يؤكد على هدف الحكومه
المدنيه
للمزيد من الاخبار والمعلومات دائما
تابعوا العربيه في امان الله
[موسيقى]